what he's the mysterious rock-and-roll
genius of French fashion Eddie Salman of
sail Iran from 2000 to 2007 he dominated
at Dior he went underground for a while
moving to Los Angeles focusing on
photography until in 2012 he rocked the
fashion world taking over YSL which he
rebranded say Lorant and then went on an
unprecedented hot streak here we take a
look at the 2016 spring collection
Jim Eddie Simon is French seeing this
collection for the first time last June
all I could think about was Los Angeles
where Eddie Simon now lives not only do
you have the new garage bands that are
playing there but it's like you've also
got just the essence of the Mojo of the
past right what is the key to this just
unbelievable hot streak that Eddie Simon
has been on it's [ __ ] to buy right I say
that makes oh [ __ ] it's a madman so you
know as as much as it's very extreme on
the runway and the way he's put it
through there you can go into the store
and you can see like oh what a cool
trenchcoat stripes car awesome jeans and
stuff in addition to the really
outrageous more exotic piece right Jim
when I think of sale around Eddie Simon
I think of black black more black and
also black but that's not what these
racks are all about so why don't we dive
in and see what's going on here you've
got an evening jacket here and you know
it's like god bless them because evening
jackets are always a little bit hard to
pull off anyways it's like why not just
go for it go all the way so does Tom
Ford so it is Cavalli City salon how we
made grandma's curtains look so cool
lately is beyond me but it's an evening
jacket not for a formal event exactly
talk about our Kurt Cobain influence a
slouchy cardigan it's definitely a
rockstar staple studded leather jacket
Gram Parsons Meets The Ramones has a
little bit of a hairband yeah that's
this is was one of our favorite shirts
of the collection very acidic color
palettes wild colors wild colors David
Bowie might have done that shirt plaid
shirts are you know throughout the
collection things are worn out and have
a little bit of distressing to that way
yeah it took I took some scissors to
them yeah exactly
this is an interesting piece this is
based on a on a tapestry
he's including a lot of the buttons and
a lot of the extra paraphernalia like
the brooches comes with a close it comes
with it right you got to be brave for
that one you got to be brave always in
style and always a great purchase is
Celeron jeans this spring weight is so
light it's really nice this is the part
where I prompt to you pick your five
favorite balls from ever get about that
I got it I'm gonna start with the
sleeveless plaid shirt for me this is
very grunge it's very cool it's very of
the moment even if you tried you
couldn't rip off the sleeves of a shirt
and make
looked better he's fraid the edges the
fabric has a little bit of a crinkle to
it second choice I'm going to do another
shirt love and Hawaiian prints the
season and there's just a beauty and
this is rayon which the original
Hawaiian shirts
I can't even grab it it's so slinky the
original Hawaiian shirts were made on
rayon which is a brand comes from wood
pulp so it's actually actual fiber for
it or not even like it's synthetic if
you were this over a tank top like half
open at the beach style for days yes
okay I'd go for the camel parka right I
feel like you know this is one of those
pieces that you know you're going to
layer it in the winter or you're gonna
wear it just the teacher in the summer
yeah you know just the eccentric nosov
yes it has it's a military feeling but
then he's put this together makes it a
little bit more rock early or vintage
the low top the low top dirty studded
low talk dirty studded low top when we
saw this coming down the runway
instantly we all look down at our feet
and we had our pristine white sneakers
yeah we just wanted to hide them you
know even the bottoms are a little bit
messed up but doesn't mean they're not
gonna last a long time and get even
better with age you got one more mr.
more I'd be remiss if I didn't say this
is a badass leather jacket is Bruno Mars
young thug Mark Ronson future is you're
definitely going to turn some heads come
spiderweb studs a month or two salary
but completely worth it you know usually
I pick a couple but for this I've got my
eye on one thing and one thing only the
mighty mighty t-rex that's great when I
first saw this is just a hole you would
never know that it's Saint Laurent
necessarily but at the same time it
couldn't be anyone else and I just think
it's ferocious it's like a little 80s a
little 90s and frankly just reminds me
of being a kid so there you have it
maybe the coolest hottest guy in fashion
right now question mark at a salon of
Saint Laurent that's the spring 2016
collection shall we mr. Moore